it has now been 7 months sinceer Bush
flipped the bird to its customer base
and then doubled and tripled down on the
insult in the expectation that the
boycott would eventually collapse and
the customers would just forget and move
on and I am pleased to report that none
of that has happened AB inbev better
known aser bush is the world's largest
Brewer it saw its Revenue climb 5% in
the July to September period in line
with Wall Street predictions
but ABM dev's Revenue in the United
States did not grow it fell it fell by
13.5% Us sales of budlight were down a
full 29% over the four weeks ending on
October 21st compared to that same
period last year which means the boycott
has not L up at all which means and this
is what matters for us
that is a winning issue for
conservatives
when the squishes beg us to lay off the
so-called social issues including and
especially LGBT issues show them these
numbers remind them that social issues
are a pretty important part of
society and point out that no other
issue perhaps in my lifetime has been a
clearer or more reliable winner for
persuading people to side with
conservatives I'm Michael nlls this is
the Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the
show the reason that this issue is
sticky the reason that the keeps
cropping up as a winner for
conservatives I think is as much
aesthetic as anything else which we'll
get to in one second this episode though
is brought to you by good ranchers claim
your year of free meat 15 bucks off and
free shipping with my code nolles at
goodranchers.com I had some juicy good
ranchers chicken stir fry the other
night it was very very
good the
reason alone but time
I'm with you now speaking of Aesthetics
and politics I debated even bringing
this story up because it's a mean nasty
story and so I'm not going to play the
clip there was a clip of the podcaster
Patrick Bet David making fun of Rona
santis and Governor Dan santis is on the
podcast and people have been making fun
of the governor for wearing boots that
seem like they have a little lift in the
heel because Donald Trump is very tall
Ronda santis he's not short he's just a
sort of averaged height guy and but in
presidential elections usually the
taller candidate wins so
some have suggested that the governor
like many politicians before him is
wearing some kind of lift in his shoes
the governor and his team have denied
this and so this podcaster Patrick vet
David decided to make fun of him and
said hey man what's the deal with the
shoes these shoes are weird you you got
you're wearing lifts here I'm going to
buy you a pair of Ferra and and Governor
Dan santis said I can't accept gifts you
know just shut it down as quickly as he
could why do the shoes matter why do
people care Governor Ronda santis the
greatest governor in America right now
maybe the greatest governor in my
lifetime very serious man who's
accomplished a lot why do they care if
he puts lifts in his shoes
because people crave confidence this is
always true and if you put lifts in your
shoes it speaks to a sort of insecurity
even if it's a well-calculated
insecurity it's it still shows an
insecurity and so people don't like that
that there's nothing new about that
people are always attracted to confident
people but I think they're especially
attracted to confident people now and
the reason that they're especially
attracted to confident people now is
because we live in a time that is
pervaded by
skepticism where we're told that we
can't really know anything for certain
we're told
that long-established facts well that's
just your opinion man we're taught that
basic philosophical premises are just
you know that's just what you think you
can't prove that how do you know you
don't know it's just your belief dude
come on man it's it's the big laow well
that's just your opinion man so in this
extremely skeptical age especially in
this extremely skeptical age any show of
confidence is very attractive I think
this helped Donald Trump who may have
been wrong a handful of times in his
life but he's never been in doubt I
think that's why people are attracted to
Trump I think why people are attracted
to AOC AOC is wrong about almost
everything but she's always so confident
about it and and someone
simply stating a
fact in a in a time of skepticism is is
really attractive and someone who
appears to have
insecurities even from the aesthetic
perspective is not going to do as well
and podcasters are going to make fun of
him like Patrick B David speaking of
political confidence xiin ping over in
China has reportedly purged 500,000 CCP
officials in just the year
2023 and this is being reported as a
horrible thing but it should be clear
when they say he purged these officials
they're not talking entirely about
stalinesque Mass executions there have
been some party members who've gone
missing at least for periods of time and
but BR when they're talking about
500,000 people purged from the Communist
Party they're talking about people who
were fired and brought up on charges and
and punished for for corruption uh this
is call me crazy I don't want to see
like I'm a she apologist here or like
I'm Pro but isn't that good isn't it
good to get rid of and punish not not
like get rid of but you know like fire
and punish the corrupt people in your
government what shouldn't we be doing
that wouldn't that be good if we if we
also did that we we never do that no one
who engages in corruption in our
government gets in trouble Republicans
get in trouble for not engaging in
corruption Democrats engage in
widespread corruption the president of
the United States along with his son and
his brother shook down leaders around
the world for millions and millions of
dollars they we we have copies of the
checks of the payments from the bagman
to the big guy up top the Oval Office
occupant Joe Biden himself and it
doesn't matter doesn't matter whatsoever
and and forget about the electeds for a
second what about all the bureaucrats we
always are complaining about the Deep
State the administrative State well what
we need to do is Purge the Deep State
and the administrative State not in the
Stalin way but not totally dissimilar
from the xiin pingue we need to fire
them get them out of their positions of
power and if they've committed crimes we
need to try them for those
crimes the federal bureaucracy is
hundreds of it's millions of people
actually depends on exactly how you
count it but it could be up to two
million people most presidents who come
into office are able to swap out four to
5,000 people in the bureaucracy in order
to have anything even resembling
meaningful change you would have to swap
out 40 to 50,000 at least
so I look at she here and I think well I
don't like communism I'm not rooting for
America's adversary Over America I'd
like America to be really strong too but
one way to be strong is when we see our
adversaries do things that are effective
and that are helping their countries
maybe we ought to learn that lesson
too now if we're going to engage in any
kind of serious political action we're
going to want our bodies to be feeling
good which is why we're going to want to
check out good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code nolles
there's a lot at St steak this November
so don't be chicken and shop at the
grocery store like usual instead head on
over to good ranchers no that's not a
pun that's just a great place good
ranchers this is my only problem with
being on the road I like being on the
road I'm in a fun location right now but
it means I eat less squid ranchers
because it's all in my freezer at home
and sweet little Lisa can only well she
can only make it four or five nights a
week sometimes for breakfast too their
Black Friday your way sale is live it's
you don't want to miss they've got great
meat puns they've got even better meat
this November you get to pick your
favorite meat to get free for a year
pick a year of free steak salmon chicken
or bacon when you subscribe to any box
right now man that is crazy it's a crazy
deal I'm I'm reading this for the first
time now that's outrageous better yet
when you subscribe to any boox on
goodranchers.com you not only get a free
gift of meat worth up to 480 bucks but
you also get up to $15 off with code
nolles K wle they got the best me meat
out there you're going to get a year of
free meat 15 bucks off free shipping
with code NES it it totally sells itself
it's number one place in America to get
all your meat and seafood by the way and
chicken and pork and all of it
goodranchers.com right now use code
nolles K
wle speaking of
purges democrats for years now have been
talking about packing the Supreme Court
and they want to pack the Supreme Court
because the court has generally
ruled in favor of conservatives on at
least least a handful of important cases
not all the important cases the Supreme
Court with the support of allegedly
conservative Justice Gorsuch
enshrined into civil rights law that's
not very conservative the Supreme Court
redefined marriage now of course that
was before some of the for all of the
Trump nominees got there but still there
were conservatives on the court they
redefined marriage in
oberfell they ratified Obamacare which
was completely unconstitutional they've
done all sorts of things but they've
also overruled roie Wade they've also
ruled in favor of the Second Amendment
they so they've done things that the
Democrats don't like and the Democrats
have said okay we're going to pack the
Supreme Court but that's politically
unpopular because it it seems as though
Democrats are upending our system of
government and the moderate Democrats
and The Independents and the kind of
just fashionable liberals they don't
like that that doesn't pull very well or
play well in Peoria so the Democrats
have a new strategy they're going to do
reverse Court packing I've got to thank
Ken kukowski over at Breitbart for that
phrase uh in a a recent write up
yesterday or the day before uh he
pointed out that reverse Court packing
will have much the same effect as
regular Court packing but it will be
more U acceptable to the public and what
is reverse Court packing reverse Court
packing is when the Democrats go in and
try to get the conservative judges to
recuse themselves from a bunch of cases
or ideally to
resign and how are they going to do that
they're going to say that uh Clarence
Tom went on vacation once and he didn't
pick up his breakfast tab the host of a
conference picked up the breakfast Tab
and so that's a bribe and even if
Clarence Thomas has never ruled on any
cases that really pertain to these
people it's just a it's it's bribery
it's
corruption Joe Biden is meanwhile just
collecting check's hand over fist
millions of dollars from China from
Ukraine from all over the world no no no
that's not forget about that pay no
attention to the man behind the curtain
Clarence Thomas he went to a summer camp
once and so he's got to resign from the
Supreme Court they're doing it to AO too
now are they going to go after him
they're going to go after Leonard Leo so
Leonard Leo is the head of the
Federalist Society Federalist Society
very important conservative legal
organization which provided a lot of the
good judges during the Trump
Administration and it's it's important
to the conservative legal ecosystem so
Senate Democrats Dems on the Senate
Judiciary Committee have decided to
subpoena Leonard Leo and others even
though Leo's attorneys are saying you
have no right to subpoena me I'm a
private citizen you you're not charging
me with a crime you have there's no
reason for you to subpoena me a private
citizen and you certainly have no right
to
subpoena Clarence Thomas or or Sam
Alo because to do so to say that the the
US Congress has some ultimate
oversight rights over the Supreme Court
is to say that the Supreme Court is
subservient to the Congress which is not
true we have three branches of
government and we have a separation of
powers we have checks and balances so
it's just completely Preposterous but
what else are they going to do this is
Dick Durban and Sheldon White House the
two Democrats who are demanding all of
these records because they think if they
can get Leo then Leo will probably go to
some of these conferences and different
nefarious back room smoke fil room kind
of things with with conservative judges
and then they'll be able to force them
to resign which will be more effective
at tilting the court in favor of
Democrats than uh packing it which is
unpopular so there's more than one way
to skin a cat Democrats are very clever
at these kinds of tactics unfortunately
if it starts to look like this is going
to work we're going to have to do the
same thing to them I don't want to I
don't want to go digging through Elena
kagan's trash can I don't want to go
hire a private eye to follow Sonia sod
myor around I don't want to have
republicans in Congress subpoena private
citizens who one time had lunch with any
of the liberal judges but we will have
to do that
because such a thing would not be
immoral it would be somewhat Reckless to
our political system when the Democrats
initiate this kind of action but it
wouldn't be immoral it would be
perfectly just it just wouldn't wouldn't
really have a place in our system but
but that kind of retaliation would be
just and not to retaliate in that way
would be to concede the political order
to the libs which would be very very
unjust so they want to go down this road
it looks like they've come to their
senses on actually packing the Supreme
Court for positively packing the Supreme
Court so now they're going to try to
negatively pack the Supreme Court and
we're going to have to hit them if they
do it to us there's there's no way out
of that the only way out is through
speaking of the Supreme Court and
speaking of the Court generally ruling
with conservatives on some big cases
even on what has been hailed a
conservative wins some conserv are
saying actually it constitutes a loss
and Senator Josh Holly wants to reverse
a Supreme Court decision largely Hil as
a republican Victory and that is the
citizens united decision so the citizens
united decision is what 10 years old now
maybe more and it says that corporations
are
people and that is the famous line from
Mitt Romney during 2012 one of the real
hits from that doomed campaign where he
said ha corporations are people my
friend
and there's some truth to that a
corporation is not just a building a
corporation is not but a corporation is
also not an individual a corporation is
a group of people with certain rights
and certain restrictions on it and what
citizens united did according to Barack
Obama and the Liberals is it allowed
corporations to spend whatever they
wanted on politics and political
campaigns now Sam Alo the conservative
judge said that's not true in fact when
Obama was Haring the court for that
during the State of the Union visibly
said not true but now Josh Holly has
come out and basically sided with
Obama and his reasoning is pretty
interesting here he says politically
connected corporations quote have been
in favor of almost everything that has
been devastating for us Beyond economics
he says what's new in the last two or
three years is that those corporations
now want to dictate voting laws in the
states they now want to dictate rules on
biological Men playing women's sports so
the old knock the old left knock on
corporations in politics is well they're
just going to spend money to buy
politicians so that the politicians
write the laws so the corporations make
more money that would be bad enough that
happens all the time in politics that
would be bad enough but what Holly is
saying is no no no this is even worse
the corporations now want to rewrite the
voting laws corporations want to rewrite
anthropology they want to rewrite what
girl Sports it means they want to upend
all of our values and our beliefs and
that's a bridge to Far So then this is
my favorite answer someone asks
Holly uh is he only going after the
corporations now because they're liberal
and I love his answer was well actions
do have
consequences I'd love that he doesn't
even try to hide it it says yeah of
course if the corporations were just
being normal and saying and we should
all live in a normal flourishing way I
wouldn't really have a problem with it
but if the corporations are going to
come in and wield their immense power in
this country country especially after
many decades of deregulation largely
heralded largely largely propelled by
conservatives then we're going to have
to reain that in this is a big
difference here between a Libertarian
and a conservative Libertarians oppose
big government conservatives oppose
outsize everything all kind of outsize
power the Libertarians they Focus their
ey on the state and the statists and the
government and yeah that's you don't
want the the government or the state to
have an outsized degree of power but big
corporations can wield power unjustly
and can threaten our rights and our way
of life just as well as the government
in some cases the corporations can do it
in a more effective way because they're
even less accountable very often than
the government is I don't want some
bureaucrat and DC stomping out my rights
in my way of life I also don't want some
weirdo at Google doing the same
thing speaking of protecting ourselves
when you want to protect your body you
got to check out bulletproof everyone
right now go to bulletproof everyone.com
us promo code nolles we'd like to thank
the sponsor of today's show bulletproof
everyone because bulletproof everyone is
a premier American Body Armor
manufacturer and supplier designed and
built for everyday wear their unique
armor systems offer 25% more coverage
than standard armor while maintaining
flexibility and all day wearability
bulletproof everyone's ultra light armor
system is so light and thin you might
just forget you're wearing it your
safety and discretion is their top
concern unless someone puts their hands
on you no one will have any clue that
you're protected with bulletproof
everyone you are not a walking billboard
there are no visible logos and no flashy
designs their comfortable tailor made
clothing system goes above and beyond
adding additional security by keeping
you Incognito and under the radar work
or Play Bulletproof everyone has got the
perfect armor system to fit your
everyday lifestyle and everyday budget
right now our listeners can get 10% off
plus free Bulletproof backpack with the
purchase of any bulletproof clothing
just use code nolles kwes at check out
at bulletproof everyone.com that is
bulletproof everyone.com promo code
nolles speaking of dubious political
speech there was a a threat made
multiple threats made to Jewish students
of
Cornell and I'm going to Cornell on
Monday so this interested me even more
than the usual threats made on campuses
so I look at
it said okay I'm think this is a legit
threat meaning I don't think it's a hoax
I don't think it's the Jewish students
sending it to themselves students have
done that usually not Jewish students
but black students have done that many
times which I outline in my book
speechless I'm on the road right now so
there's no there there's no Bell sadly
uh you you've seen this on sexual hoaxes
women claiming to have been raped on
college campuses and then evidence comes
out that it just wasn't true meanwhile
the men's Li lives have been ruined by
some Kangaroo Court of professors and
diversity
Deans but usually Jewish students don't
do that so I said I think I I I think
this one is probably legit it turns out
that it is legit a student from upstate
New York has been arrested for making
these threats and the student is
ethnically
Asian which is that's not that's not
supposed to be how it works hold on the
student the threat was made against the
Jewish students so the person who made
the threat has to be a Neo-Nazi white
supremacist so the student ha the
student has to be white ideally for the
liberal media this threat would have
been made by a white student and then we
could have had weeks and weeks of a
national conversation about white
supremacy and how white men with their
toxic masculinity and their evil palad
whiteness they need to be run out of
society so that would have been ideal
for the
Liberals second to that the student was
supposed to be
Arab Arabs were considered white for
statistical purposes in the US for a
long time until it became clear that
being white was a disadvantage in uh
politics so then all of a sudden that
that kind of went away uh and and that
there was a new group The Mina the
Middle East North Africa group there
were some Arab and Middle Eastern
political activists who said we want a
separate category because we're so
oppressed you think hold on wait a
second if you're being oppressed
by the evil white man and you're
currently being classified as white
shouldn't you want to just keep being
class wouldn't that that would lessen
your oppression
if what you were saying were true but
it's not actually the opposite is true
so at least the guy was supposed to be
Arab and he was supposed to be a Hamas
sympathizer but he's
not he's he's
Asian what do we do with
that I I imagine what we're going to do
is that the story is going to disappear
because these stories do do not make it
to the
news because of the stories themselves
the stories make it to the news because
of the narratives that already existed
and the stories are
selected according to the narratives if
they fit the narrative the stories get
selected and you hear about them and
they become a cause celeb and we now
think of George Floyd as some kind of
secular Saint even
though black men are killed in violent
ways every day in the unit United States
and criminals are are killed in violent
ways every day in the United States and
drug addicts who take lethal doses of
drugs overdose on those drugs every day
in the United States and people aren't
killed by the police quite so constantly
as the left says but policing is a
dangerous job and you're dealing with
criminals and there are officer involved
shootings the reason George Floyd made
it of course is because his story fit
the narrative and all the other stories
that don't fit the narrative you just
never hear of same is true here I doubt
we're going to hear very much more about
this fellow at Cornell maybe maybe I'll
hear about it though when I go up to
Cornell on Monday speaking of people
threatening to kill the
Jews the
hooes the hooes it sounds like a 50s
dwop band or something but it's an
Iranian backed yemeni terror group has
just declared war on Israel so now we
got we have the state of Israel was
attacked by Hamas Hamas runs the Gaza
Strip Gaza is one of the Palestinian
territories Hamas is funded by
Iran Hezbollah just North of Israel runs
the south of Lebanon Hezbollah then gets
in on the action pretty
quickly then you have other Terror
groups attack us bases because us is
allied with Israel in Syria and Iraq so
now then
Israel bombs an airport in Syria so now
we got we got Syria pretty well involved
now we go down the Arabian Peninsula we
seem to have Yemen
involved and Yemen already was in the
midst of a sort of Civil War and was
already getting bombed by the Saudis so
now they're sending missiles to the
Israelis but their missiles aren't that
good so
anyway I say all of this to underline a
point that I've made from the beginning
of this war which
is this thing could and very likely will
spiral out of control very very
quickly and
different nations have different
interests here the interest of Iran is
to obliterate Israel from the face of
the Earth the interest of Israel is
to prevent Palestinian statehood at the
very least and almost certainly to Annex
Gaza or render Gaza politically neutral
and send all the gazans to Egypt which
the Egyptians don't want to have
happen and another desire of Israel will
be to have regime change in Iran
and this person has this wish and this
person has that wish and this person has
this wish and the interest of the United
States is to contain the war that's our
interest that's our strategic vital
interest is containing this war before
it spins out of control that's a
different National interest than Iran
certainly it's different National
interest than Israel it's different
National interest than the Palestine
Liberation movement it's different
different peoples have different
interests that one is ours contain the
war because it continues to spin out of
control CL containing the war means
wrapping it up as quickly as
possible without risking that it will
erupt again too soon it's going to erupt
again this this kind of a conflict has
been going on in this way for well over
a hundred years and it's been going on
more broadly for Millennia it's not
going to end there's not going to be any
final end to this
war so you you could say all right we we
want to wrap the war up so let's just
have a ceasefire immediately well is
that going to solve the problem if Hamas
continues to rule in
Gaza then Israel can't feel safe in any
way and the the war is just going to
erupt again in two seconds so you cannot
allow Hamas to continue ruling in Gaza
but then what do you do do you then just
totally glass Gaza and and genocide all
the Palestinians or send them to Egypt
which Egypt's not going to take them uh
no I don't think that's going to work I
don't I don't see Iran or any of the
other Arab states and they were just
rolling over for
that what do you do it's very tricky if
I had the answer I would well I i' said
I would win a Nobel Prize but they don't
give Nobel prizes to conservatives or
people who fix things they only give
Nobel prizes to people who make things
worse and to liberals but I repeat
myself so if I had the answer though I
would be the wisest Statesman of the
last 100 years so I'll let you know when
I come up with it speaking of
allies there is a min OTA Schoolboard
candidate who is insistent on giving
kids little kids a way to identify
allies to talk
[Music]
about now speaking of crime convicting a
murderer the new 10-part docu series by
Candace Owens and dailywire plus has
done an excellent job at convincing even
the strongest of Steven Avery supporters
that he is guilty if you have not seen
the full series all episodes are now
available exclusively on dailywire plus
the final episode reveals who the real
villains of the story are Steven Avery
his family and the filmmakers who
portrayed him as innocent and fooled
millions of viewers here is a teaser of
the
series going to direct your attention
specifically
to October 31st of
2005 you need to tell us about this so
we know you're telling us the truth so
ski stabs her first and then you cut her
next we sat at her house and waited for
the garage door to open hoping that she
was coming
back garage are never
opened it's almost as if she was
murdered and then murdered Again by
these two documentary
makers I
[Music]
love my sisters and my whole
family
[Music]
you can binge all 10 episodes now but
only if you're a dailywire plus member
so sign up today at dailywire.com
subscribe to watch the entire series my
favorite comment yesterday this is
actually not even from yesterday's
episode this is from my interview my
spooky Halloween uh interview with a
former witch you get that now on YouTube
the name is seeking truth in God comment
is I was into witchcraft for three
decades I'm now Christian in part
because of the men of the daily wire
thank you I'm very glad to hear that
that's really terrific uh glad glad that
we could be part of that journey of
yours and if you haven't seen the
interview go check it out it's available
now you can watch it even after
Halloween speaking of leading kids
astray you remember Boston Children's
Hospital got
[Music]
caught speaking of troubled children and
speaking of all that boring house
oversight
the stuff they're uncovering is good
stuff it's good stuff even if it's not
going to persuade your average voter on
The Suite it will certainly persuade the
high information voters who were
listening to this particular program but
they got him you you've been hearing
from Joe Biden from the beginning well
where's the money show me the money show
me where the graft is here here's where
the graft is in July of 2019 this
courney of the house oversight committee
this is three months after Joe Biden
announced he was running for president
hunter gets a quarter million dollar
loan from a Chinese business associate
this is the wire that goes to Hunter
that used Joe Biden's Delaware home as
the beneficiary address so
it's I guess the consolation is they're
Crooks but and they're pretty good at it
but they make Elementary mistakes like
that Joe Biden's address is
on listed as the beneficiary address
well now we know neither Hunter nor Joe
Biden paid back that loan instead
Democrat donor and Hollywood lawyer
Kevin Morris acquired Hunter Biden's
stake in Boh High Harvest rst which is
one of these sketchy China deals and
then this guy just assumed the debt for
Hunter he just assumed the quarter
million
dollars why why did he do that because
they were long-standing
friends childhood friends and he just
felt bad for poor old Hunter who he was
struggling with drugs and had a no they
actually only met in
2019 at a political fundraiser at a
political fundraiser for Joe Biden's
campaign so they meet at this political
fundraiser they say oh hey you're a Joe
Biden's son right cool how can I bribe
you oh cool I can assume this loan that
was never going to be paid back anyway
from your crooked counterparts in China
okay
great so house oversight asks why is a
Democrat donor taking on Hunter's China
debt raise a serious ethical questions
yeah of course I love this stuff I
encourage James comr and the house
oversight committee to keep digging it
up I I like to be able to have proof
when people make silly claims like there
is no evidence that Joe Biden took
bribes or anything like that I I like to
be able to refute
that it's not going to matter people
know Joe Biden just like people know
Donald Trump people know Joe Biden they
know that he is a simpering backs
slapping empty suit of a politician they
know he's dirty they know he takes
bribes they know it doesn't
matter just like people know Donald
Trump he can be nasty sometimes he says
mean things he he is loose with his
language he's unpredictable politically
yeah yeah we all know
that this is why it's it's not going to
work the the candidates who are running
against Trump in the primary and they
they keep pointing out all the problems
with
Trump that his opponents pointed out in
2016 but we know him he's he's one of
the most famous men in the world okay
the guy's been famous since the 80s and
then he was the president of the United
States he was the star of a of a major
Network TV show for 12 years or
something or more then he was the
president yeah we know we know him and
We Know Joe Biden and none of this is
going to make a
difference when I see these these weak
attacks on Trump this did you see Donald
Trump misspoke this man he's not the
same man as 20 what are you talking he
is exactly the same man he also misspoke
in 2016 and no one
cares or some people care but they
already don't like
him did you see Joe Biden took a bribe
yeah
uhhuh I did I did see that that's not
going to matter that's not what's going
to move the needle what's really going
to move the needle in this election as
far as I'm concerned is how voter ID
ballot harvesting and mail and ballots
are are orchestrated in The crucial
swing States I think that's going to be
the big difference and I think the
candidates are
basically already
said speaking of government payoffs
there is I'm going to have to tease this
I'm not I want to you know me I'm a
tease I want to get into this story but
it's this
trucker who absolutely destroys the
liberal argument for why we all need to
be driving electrical
vehicles uh in in about two seconds he
knocks it down and the reason I'm
teasing this is not just CU I think the
electric vehicle fat is silly and you
know if the technology is going to come
about it can come about over time but
the idea that the government is forcing
us all to convert our normal cars into
these electrical monstrosities is so so
ridiculous to what to stop us from being
burned to death by the sun monster in 12
what did AOC said 12 years how many
years ago was that we'll see we'll see
when the time runs out uh but the the
reason I look forward to playing this
clip for you either tomorrow or sometime
the next week is
it reminds us of two things that are
really missing in our government and our
politics right now and that would be
knowledge and competence all right on
that note that's our show I'm Michael
nlls this is the Michael nlls show see
you
[Music]
tomorrow